the nominees for the best scoring the  orchestra likes him the nominees for the  best scoring either original song score  or adoption or adaptation our Barry  Lyndon adapted by Leonard Rosenman funny  lady adapted by Peter Matz  Tommy adapted by Peter Townsend and the  winner is letter Roseman for Barry  Lyndon  thank you very much to the members of  the Academy for voting me this  prestigious award also thanks to Stanley  Kubrick who had more faith am I getting  this than I did also thanks to our  Neutral attorney and benevolent  avuncular guide lui blah felt the same  way  - Larry Marx of Warner Brothers music  thanks for putting together what is in  my estimation a magnificent soundtrack  album and also - George Friedrich Handel  Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart Antonio Vivaldi  etc thank you very much